you have to be very very careful with
that though because
someday your publisher may come to you
and say we would like to do a map
and it won't require any work from you
we'll just take the maps in the book and
blow them up and you'll say oh that'll
be a good idea you'll give me money for
that and they'll say yes we will
and
then they'll blow up the maps and
they'll call you up and say
you know that map that was in the front
of your paperback when we blow it up to
poster size it's a lot of blank spaces
can you kind of
fill that in
so then you find yourself drawing a lot
of little mountains and forests
the purple mountains that's from that
song
[Music]
then you turn in the map that you get
all filled up and and they say well this
is great for the map of westeros how
about the world map
no okay uh here here's the world map i i
got it it's mostly blank but i'll fill
that into and then they fill it up
hippographs lots of hippogriffs
okay the city carth that you have way
over here on the uh
on the edge of the page here to the east
there's a line in book three where like
karth is
equidistant between east and west
could you invent a similar amount of
stuff
in the east
that you already have to the west
17 new countries and
all that
the pointy map no i
i already used the pointy mountains
so maps can take more time than you
think
[Laughter]
but anyway if you want to know where a
lot of fantasy maps come from
you know take a look at any any
map in the front of your favorite
fantasy book and turn it upside down
you know my westeros began as upside
down ireland
[Laughter]
you can see the fingers of the dingle
peninsula and stuff like that i changed
things
yeah you look at robin hobb's six
duchies it's upside down in alaska
here's a live in my map i go okay
i'm i've got the colored pencils right
and i've got a graph paper because you
got a 10h
10b
full range you know
that'd be telling and
and so i i know a big chunk of this
story is going to have to happen in a
big city so i go right
why do you have a big city
well it's usually a conflict of trade
routes
okay so what makes trade routes and i'm
like well rivers are really influential
there and there's some political
boundaries but let's start with the
river and i go
so where do rivers come from
like so i look at like there's mountains
and then there's the land and then
there's aquifers and like
okay so how does an aquifer
work so i started doing this research
and eventually
that's the secret is to effectively
become infinitely recursive
and uh
and then 14 years later you eventually
finish your math
that's not advice actually
the day after comes out you get a letter
from a geologist
you've got the tectonic plates wrong
you know what and just
to put a bow on the whole map thing the
question
that i like to ask when i find myself
feeling compelled to write anything or
do anything in a book as i say
why
am i doing a math
and if the answer is because i like maps
that's okay but then i'm like why should
i feel obliged to have a map in my
fantasy book
and the answer is usually wow you just
kind of do with secondary world fantasy
then you go well why is that
well because everyone does well why does
everyone
well token did
[Music]
i would suggest the answer is so people
will know where things are
but i actually think
that's too easy
the granddaddy of fantasy and his shadow
is long
and
but why did tolkien have a map
in his book
because there was a map in his book in
the story it was a part of the story
and so when you like they bring out the
map
and like thorin is like there and
they're in rivendell and elrond says oh
moon letters you go oh [ __ ] wow and you
flip to that one there it is it's here i
get to see the map that they're seeing
and so token had the very good reason
for putting that in there and of course
it gives you the sense of progress and
the ability to engage with it
but
the reason he did it
is not necessarily the reason you should
do it if you're just kind of following
in the tradition without the thought
towards the ultimate purpose and how it
serves the story you've left the path of
wisdom
that's my second talking quote right and
and similarly a lot of people follow in
tolkien's footsteps you think if i'm
writing a fantasy novel i need to have a
bunch of creative languages
because tolkien did it and it's kind of
become a tradition
but tolkien didn't do it for tradition
he did it because he was a language geek
and that's what he loved
and i am not a linguist
and so i kind of i need that to make my
world realistic but i don't geek out
over it i'm a geek for currency
and so my economy i actually have it all
worked out and that filters into my
books
and so that's important nobody ever
spends money in tolkien's books because
he obviously didn't care
that wasn't a thing for him
and so
when people asked about what he did care
when they stopped paying him royalty
that would have come out in the sequel
but when people say you know what should
we do i'd say you're a geek for
something and if that's like herbology
or like the the nature of the night sky
or plate tectonics it's like revel in
your geekery roll around in it and make
that a part of your world because that
will be really interesting to the people
reading because you're interested in it
whereas if you try to do something
because you feel like you're supposed to
i don't think that's the best way to
really enjoy yourself and make make a
vibrant world
did something kind of interesting in the
maps and boarded rings i remember when i
read it for the first time because the
first map you encounter in that folk is
the map of the shire and of course it
fills the entire cage here's the west
farthing and the south farthing and the
these farthing and the north carolina
thing very imaginatively named
habiton in the middle of it and you know
and
you're reading it and it's like okay i'm
reading a book that's set in this world
called the shire and this is the big
place and he's talking about how the
people in the north shire or the north
farthing are different from the people
in the east barthing and the ones that
live down the river and have people here
and you're thinking well this is
obviously very important because he's
devoting so much time to it
and then they leave the shop
and you know they cross the barrel down
they get the ribbon down and suddenly
you've got another map and like you can
barely find this guy
that's this little tiny kind of thing
over here and there's a whole gigantic
world and there's this wonderful feeling
of holy [ __ ] i've just been reading
about the back yard here
an epic journey to get from hobbiton to
bree and you know the big danger was the
the mushroom farmer
really there's more going on in this as
an enormous world and i love that
feeling that it did sort of that you
pulled the rug out from under you the
first map is just a faint